[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
oh yeah it's like being on stage in the
band cuz the cameras are very high
quality at for the time I've never seen
anything that makes you feel quite so
involved with the performance the
quality of the shots is amazing really
amazing but the energy is there my God
there's a lot of energy and the great
surprise for me was how good we were
[Music]
we'd been around South America doing a
lot of shows with them we were flying
high there were four of us you know we
were going on in front of 100,000 people
no support act you didn't know what they
were going to think so you better be
good you better not be semi-professional
we had a little period off and then we
convened just to do this in just these
two shows there were two nights in
Montreal it was always great I love
Montreal I love the people I love the
city we shot this double anamorphic and
you're talking about film of course
there's no digital in sight in those
days it's funny also to see all the
wires you the wires on the microphone
and the guitar that was life in those
days very different and it's a four
piece there's no keyboards there's no
percussion nothing extra and God it
rocks I mean as Roger said when we we
finished watching it bloody hell we
weren't bad were we you know it gills
together really
[Music]
[Applause]
well it's fascinating to realize that in
1981 and the performance was so free
there was so much invention we didn't
quite know where we might know what song
we were doing next but we didn't know
quite what we're going to do with it and
it was so it's different every night and
I think you know you realize the
chemistry was so magical we're very
conscious of each other but also the
looseness is great because we're able to
interact with each other and change
things as we go along well it was all I
eyeball you know we would just start
stuff and where you going with this
where you going what do you want to do
now you know and that's great that's
what it's all about we were playing real
music in front of a lot of people
bouncing off one another and they R
diging it that's what it's all about
we're just kind of loosely feeling
things out and then it kicks into the
actual beat of the song the energy in
there is incredible Roger and I both
felt we learned something looking at our
younger selves and thinking yeah we
could do a little bit more of that we
could be a little more loose with each
other little bit more
experimental by that point we we're kind
of at a peak and I think Freddy was at a
peak he was physically absolutely on top
so fit and his voice is great he's not
suffering is not fighting any sort of
injury to his voice it's beautifully
crystal clear on IMAX it's astonishing
isn't it wonderful to see how his face
works and his muscles work and how his
mustache
works it's something you you really
treasure these days you want to see
every breath he takes why not you know
it makes us very emotional seeing that
my God he was good Fred was just the
most inspiring uh front man he was
wonderful I have no bad memories just
Joy working with him I think it comes
over actually in this film I guess it's
a good snapshot of uh Freddy probably
near the height of his powers uh and the
band it's very interesting for me it was
very interesting
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
we were doing it we were annoyed because
there were cameras there cuz we didn't
really want cameras there didn't want to
be
filmed uh Fred was in a bad mood with
our manager so everything's a little bit
fast but sometimes little bit fast is
quite good and it gives it an edge so
there's actually more tension than there
would normally be in the playing and I
think I can see that it's quite tur and
some of the the tempos are quite fast Ty
Mother Down is as I remember it that's
faster than we normally would have
played Ty mother down maybe that's for
the
good oh I hope they take joy I hope
they're uplifted I hope they en enjoy
the songs and the performances it's
really about the performance and the
interaction between the band it's all
real and I think if you're playing music
to people you should be real this is a
good example of that well here you're
looking at a band which is still hungry
and still quite young and full of energy
and thriving on the audience that we're
building and it's a moment in time it's
not perfect but it's not bad for a four
piece who are just out there giving it
everything they
got are the
champions my
friend and we be
my to
the oh oh we are the
champions We Are the
Champions no time for
loser we
[Music]
are of the
world